qué tanto tiempo tomará el kremlin para
aceptar los resultados de los referendos
y anexar estos territorios tal Como hizo
con crimea en 2014 y por otro lado Busca
Rusia decir que están atacando su
territorio con armas de la otan
Buenas noches Andrés si efectivamente
esto ya sucedió en 2014 fue la misma
historia misma libreto es más que diría
yo que estar retardo aunque esto
sucediera y ahora se unen digamos a un
instrumento jurídico interno de Rusia
para efectivamente decir estos
territorios rusos a partir de ese
momento a cualquier
toque con armamento ofensivo hacia
territorio
es un ataque a territorio Ruso y podemos
extender la escalada que no no quisiera
realmente tener que en algún momento
comentar pero realmente es muy muy muy
muy tensionante muy peligroso y hacemos
algo más estamos al borde O sea ya ya
empezó 21 de Septiembre ya empezó la
entrada en el otoño y Próximamente en
invierno y Esto va a ser realmente
complicado porque es este ejército ruso
está formado para combatir en invierno
entonces más la movilización que no es
parcial es total en Rusia pues llevar
una a una guerra realmente muy fuerte
tipo Segunda Guerra Mundial de o primera
con toda la movilización con todo fuego
a potencia y no sabemos dónde puede
terminar esto ahora qué nivel de
coerción se ha observado en estos
referendos y Por ende qué nivel de
credibilidad tiene
Bueno chao pararnos en el lado del
derecho internacional y en Las
observaciones internacionales digamos
que Si eso fuera así pues esto no
pasaría esto no no tiene no tiene
ninguna representatividad no tiene
ninguna legalidad Pero eso realmente no
en este momento eso pasa segundo plano
aquí lo que importa es que Rusia va a
tener una tiene un instrumento jurídico
para decir que atacan su territorio Y
eso lo que importa si
no lo reconoce el gobierno de kiev si no
reconocen de manera europea Bruselas la
Casa Blanca a Rusia la tiene esto sin
cuidado para ellos esto es papel mojado
lo que necesitan es tener un instrumento
jurídico interno de legitimidad para
poder desplegar armamento
de mayor intensidad en territorio contra
la otan o contra los aliados de los
aliados que tienen
dice por ejemplo que no aceptará estos
resultados qué respuesta se puede
esperar de Estados Unidos y de la
comunidad internacional
yo creo que más allá de los rechazos y
de los cantos de las compras
internacionales y demás no tiene mayor
respuesta y no tiene mayor respuesta y
además vuelvo a repetir la situación del
petróleo la situación del gas que
alimenta las centrales y la economía de
Europa va a ser muy complicada solo para
tener dos referentes
las reservas de gas de Gran Bretaña
alcanzan para siete días el momento en
que Rusia corte los suministros la
situación va a ser muy difícil para
ejemplo para Gran Bretaña y así puedo
empezar con cada país digamos que en
promedio tienen 70 80 días de reservas
de gas y eso mueve la economía de toda
esta gran Mola económica que la Unión
Europea entonces la situación es muy
compleja Unido unival unival al factor
tiempo climático que se avecina entonces
la respuesta que tienen los Estados
Unidos Más allá de seguir proveyendo
inteligencia armamento no es no no creo
que haya no tiene más que hacerle las
sanciones se han visto que no tienen han
tenido resultado las han sido birladas
de alguna manera y pues no Ya sigue
teniendo